une vitrine discrète ceinte d'un tu fais
au traditionnel c'est cette porte qu'il
faut pousser dans le vieux tours pour
découvrir l'atelier ouvert de pascal
rioult une légère odeur d'encens rappel
de suite que l'art du vitrail est avant
tout connue pour sublimer les lieux de
culte raconté illustrer des textes
sacrés ce que l'on découvre c'est que
cet art minutieux est aujourd'hui des
plus prisées pour magnifier des
intérieurs cossus de plus en plus
d'ateliers des vitraux ce qui est bien
pour le métier justement parce que ça
permet de varier les styles voilà le
métier de vitra liste a le vent en poupe
en ce moment comme décida donc du coup
les gens en effet ça leur donne des
idées le vitrail se personnalise
aujourd'hui on le commande selon ses
goûts ses inspirations
le vert crise ou d'appoint de tungstène
ils se séparent sans éclat et bien
s'ajuster précisément dans le tableau
qui prend forme
traditionnellement c'est un ruban de
plomb qui viendra sertir l'ensemble lui
donner une consistance jusqu'à ce que
l'oeuvre ne fasse plus qu'une pièce on
alterne une pièce de verre un plomb une
pièce de verre un plomb donc une façon
de faire qui est particulière il faut
que le réseau réseau de plomb ce qu'on
appelle le réseau de plans cds de la
disposition des plombs soit homogène
logique et surtout
sur une stabilité aux vitres al chaque
élément de la fresque fragile et
préalablement pain avec des pigments
humidifié délayé délicatement posée au
pinceau la cuisson fixera l'ensemble le
médium c'est à dire le produit quand
ajoute c'est soit de l'eau soit du
vinaigre blanc soit des huiles
essentielles soient plus récemment du
propylène glycol est la différence avec
tous ces médiums là c'est le résultat
sur le verre le tour demain reste le
même ancestrale précis mais l'arrivée du
numérique a quelque peu changé la donne
puisqu'il permet de créer d'ajuster la
maquette avant de la mettre en oeuvre le
vitrail se décline à l'envi aujourd'hui
en aplat imposé sur un mur façon
créations originales à reflets
changeants ou encore en simple objet à
poser du verre de la lumière est une
source d'inspiration toute particulière